et on direct avec nos sébastien boussois
docteur en sciences politiques et
spécialiste du terrorisme
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france de si bon matin est ce que vous
voyez un lien entre ces différentes
attaques qui ont touché la france hier
alors je dirais qu'il ya un contexte
évidemment qui est plutôt
malheureusement fertile à ce qui est en
train de se passer une forme de psychose
une multiplication des tensions de part
de part et d'autre et comme l'a
mentionné votre journaliste il ya d'une
part des individus qui ont commis des
actes et dont on est aujourd'hui à peu
près sûr que ce sont des attentats
terroristes islamistes et de l'autre
côté
quelques cas isolés qui à mon avis
risque de progresser de mois en mois vu
le contexte extrêmement anxiogène de
notre société qui peuvent être des cas
isolés ou psychiatrique bien évidemment
s'agirait pas de faire une sorte de
généralisation il ya derrière et en tout
cas que ce soit pour samuel pas thibout
que ce soit pour l'attentât hier à la
basilique notre-dame un fort courant
d'idéologie station chez ces individus
pour cela qu'ils les font basculer dans
l'extrémisme violent et qui les font
passer à l'acte est ce que l'acte
terroriste hier matin qui a touché à
mener c'est ce qu'il était prévisible
selon
nos confrères du figaro notamment une
note évoqué depuis dimanche dernier en
appel d'islamistes au jihad individuel
dans les églises dans les églises en
france et quand bien même quand le
président macron parle d'augmenter les
effectifs de 3000 à 7000 militaires dans
l'absolu je pense qu'il ne peut pas
faire moins il ne peut pas faire autre
par rapport à l'opinion d'un autre côté
évidemment c'est ce qui s'était passé
après 2015 et après 2016 que ce soit à
paris ou à bruxelles
il y a des brigades ou des équipements
militaires qui peuvent être de 20 chaque
lieu religieux symbolique que ce soit
une synagogue ou en l'occurrence une
église c'est impossible de prévenir
aujourd'hui ce type d'acte d'un 1 22
individus qu'ils soient isolés ou pas on
gênant dit en général que la foudre ne
frappe pas deux fois au même endroit et
nice a déjà malheureusement payé un
lourd tribut puisque on en est au
troisième attentat je crois que c'est
extrêmement compliqué aujourd'hui
d'arriver à trouver une parade dans un
terrorisme qui a changé on est plus dans
les formations paramilitaires de 2014 et
2015 ou que vous arriviez grâce aux
services à remonter la piste d'une
filière avec un ordonnateur et c'est
qu'il soit à l'étranger ou qu'ils soient
en france aujourd'hui on a un individu
le cas et dudu jeunes d'hier est tout à
fait symptomatique c'est à dire que on a
été avant sur ce qu'on appelle des
homebrews des gens qui sont menées sur
le sol de la république qui ensuite sont
partis à l'étranger puis s'en sont pris
à la france depuis quelques semaines on
est sur des profils clairement et qui
malheureusement risque de faire le jeu
des extrêmes et en l'occurrence du
rassemblement national des profils qui
viennent de l'étranger qui probablement
perturbé agité ou déterminée dans le
contexte de la rue publication des
caricatures et dans cette bronca qui a
contre la france qu'ils essayent coûte
que coûte de maintenir cette liberté
d'expression des véritables profil qu'il
soit afghan vous l'avait dit pour lyon
hier tchétchène anzor off pour pour
samuel pâtit malheureusement et le
tunisien le tunisien et hyères ou encore
le pakistanais au moment de
de l'attentât contre les anciens locaux
de charlie hebdo donc c'est un fait
c'est vraiment insaisissable c'est sa
toute la difficulté aujourd'hui de notre
combat quand révèle le profil de
l'assaillant de nice hier soir il aurait
notamment transité par lampedusa mais je
ne veux faire strictement aucune
conclusion hâtive mais il est clair que
c'est un individu qui en plus est tout à
fait hors de tout de tout fichier il est
strictement un connu au bataillon et on
peut avoir le profil d'un individu qui
effectivement est passé à travers les
mailles du filet il avait des papiers
liés à la croix rouge d'un autre côté il
était en italie devait être en
quarantaine puis l'italie lui a intimé
l'ordre de quitter le territoire
ce qu'il a fait il est venu en france et
aujourd'hui on est effectivement dans
cette problématique clair clair et net
de ces individus qui peuvent circuler
aussi facilement et qui après commette
l'irréparable
je pars faire de généralisation à ce
stade là mais c'est vrai que dans les
deux trois derniers
dernier profil on peut être dans cette
sensibilité là on peut aussi être dans
cette forme de deux profils qui passe
par ou qui viennent de pays en crise que
ce soit la tchétchénie avant en tout cas
le contexte est clair c'est que ce ne
sont pas forcément des profils qui sont
prêts à venir en france et à s'arrêter
il ya s'arrêter là tout le danger
aujourd'hui de la menace terroriste en
france c'est le fait que justement ces
individus qui commettent pour le cadre
de nice hier qui commettent des
attentats sur notre territoire
agissent à priori en dehors de tout
réseau islamiste terroriste et donc
peut-être war opérable ou moins
identifiables a priori comme comme vous
dites c'est toujours l'éternelle
problématique des loups solitaires en
réalité je crois que quelles que soient
la situation et les tags de dice
aujourd'hui qui effondré sur le sol
syrien et irakien pour un temps ou pas
aujourd'hui la démultiplication de
l'idéologie jihadiste dans
aujourd'hui que plus forte et donc il
suffit d'aller sur internet et de voir
qu effectivement on peut trouver ou
accéder encore à des contenus malgré les
combats des grands que ce soit facebook
twitter et autres
on peut rapidement se retrouver pris
dans une autre forme de solidarité ou
dans une autre forme de réseau qui est
le réseau insaisissable aujourd'hui qui
est encore internet et pour lequel vous
avez tous les outils à un moment pour
devenir un apprenti terroriste et puis
passer à l'acte regardez ce qui s'est
passé avec samuel pâti en europe a
profité malheureusement de la haine
véhiculés sur les réseaux sociaux par un
des parents de d'une des jeunes filles
qui étaient censés être en cours et qui
auraient assisté aux caricatures et du
coup aujourd'hui n'y a plus besoin
d'avoir une organisation qui va donner
des ordres qui va insuffler un mouvement
aujourd'hui les choses se font presque
naturellement c'est à dire un individu
qui va agir non plus au nom de cette
organisation
mais au nom d'une idéologie
malheureusement qui soyons clairs ne
cesse de progresser
que ce soit sur internet que ce soit
dans certains quartiers où que ce soit
dans quelques quelques mosquées bien
bien déterminée tout dernier mot parce
que le temps lui manque assez rapidement
est ce que vous vous parler du contexte
en france est ce que il est aussi un
contexte notamment de colère au
moyen-orient qui peut jouer
en colère contre le président français
emmanuel macron qui a promis que la
france ne renoncerait pas aux
caricatures du prophète mahomet ce qui a
provoqué des appels au boycott des
produits français des appels à la
manifestation et c'est ce que cela peut
avoir joué un rôle dans la table d'hier
le contexte peut avoir joué il est clair
que l'art publication des caricatures
n'est pas un acte qui me paraît un acte
d'apaisement et je crois que le rôle du
président de la république c'est d'unir
plus que diviser et à partir du moment
où sur la base de quelques attentats
terroristes ignobles
on se retrouve dans une situation ce
sont toutes les communautés musulmanes
qui ont ce sentiment de se retrouver
stigmatisés et qui du coup se risquent
de se braquer je ne crois pas que l'on
ait un intérêt à se mettre à dos la
communauté musulmane ça ne veut pas dire
ne pas lutter activement contre les
dérives qui peut y avoir au sein même de
certaines de ces communautés
mais la situation est claire à partir du
moment où le président appelle à
republier airs dispatcher les
caricatures dans les écoles je crois que
c'est tout sauf un acte qui permettent
d'apporter ce que j'avais appelé dans
une tribune de jeune afrique
une forme de concorde civile aujourd'hui
on est au bord du gouffre le processus
même de micro guerre civile tels que
dice le souhaitaient n'est plus du tout
une option n'est pas du tout impossible
donc il faut au plus vite
apaiser les choses séparées les choses
lutter activement contre l'islamisme et
ses dérivés les actes odieux qui sont
commis en le pseudo nom de l'islam et de
l'autre côté je dirais équipe est armée
les communautés musulmanes politiquement
sociologiquement économiquement
culturellement pour qu'elle puisse se
débarrasser de ces extrêmes qui
pourrissent la vie de tout le monde
merci pour votre réaction sébastien
boussois docteur en sciences politiques
et spécialiste du terrorisme